ladies and gentlemen grab your kleenex
grab something to cry into it's going to
be a very sad episode today
very serious with you guys it's going to
be about the art of how people retire on
youtube how marketers retire
very depressing please make sure you're
somewhere where you can openly cry
because compared
compared to this the notebook was a
comedy it's actually why i came in the
studio at night
i didn't want to make anyone sad during
their office day right you don't want to
cry in front of your co-workers
introducing first our first contestant
kevin david so for all of those reasons
i'm quitting youtube tell me it isn't
true kevin after all we've been through
together you and me don't quit now what
am i going to do with myself how am i
going to make youtube videos if you quit
oh i quit social media for 48 hours
but before we do actually get into all
of those i do want to take just a few
quick seconds
and address my last video about quitting
youtube because wow
tens of thousands of views in the first
couple of hours
when you retire the view counter goes
marketers are this really weird species
of human where nothing means what it
says they mean
i mean take billy gene is marketing he
didn't only quit youtube he said
he's retiring for good what's up it's
billy i know you're busy so i'll be
quick i sent this to you
in your email um but if you didn't have
a chance to read it yet i wanted to let
you know that uh
i am retiring so what i did is i took
everything i've ever created and i'm
just pretty much
giving it away giving it away which is
code
that's marketer speak for selling it for
69
that's right giving it away i'm
practically giving it away guys
for 69 and actually we learned two weeks
into his
long retirement i mean this is a man who
needs to rest from all his hard labor
teaching everyone how to market
effectively he decided to drop another
video he
came out of retirement how to create a
giveaway
that gets a ton of engagement how do you
turn a giveaway
into actual sales oh boy i feel like i
already know the answer to this
what's a simple and easy way to do you
can do it today because there's one
thing guarding interest of people who
want stuff for free pretty much
giving it away but how do you actually
translate that into money
in your pocket step one retire step two
charge 69 for your giveaway now guys the
first two i mean i know i was joking but
this one
this one really will bring a tear to
your eyes ladies and gentlemen can we
get a
sad uh some sad music going please
come on let's play i'll just start
playing some sad music
because um you know this is a very sad
moment
we have one of the greatest youtubers
mcjuggernuggets retiring guys
things would never be the same they were
actually doing us
you wanna get a close-up nick
why did he say get a close-up like as if
he's gonna say something important
but then it's just of him drinking water
why not take that out is it to make it
more sad
i have a picture of you pathetically
drinking water from a
chalice get a close-up nick
closer nick closer
get closer nick
i really want to emphasize guys this is
not a series
this is not a clickbait video i will be
officially quitting
youtube as of january 1st 2020.
january 1st 2020.
juggies this is the last video i'll ever
make on youtube
it doesn't feel real it really doesn't
it's scary for me to think that this is
the last video
i will ensure this works but i always
suck at saying goodbye
that its story fire doesn't ceced i will
die
by the fire wait what
no there's no need to do that uh
mcjuggernuggets that is my guarantee to
you
wow
no guarantee is necessary you don't have
to do i make a decision i own it and i
commit
and you guys heard it here i mean we
can't talk him out of it i will
die by the fire
i'm willing to do the hard things and
let go
of things that have been in my life
forever it's like when somebody passes
away
or you lose somebody and
you can't get them back there's so much
you want to say
or if only i did this or it'll never be
enough
and i'm sure years from now i'll be like
i wish i
i wish they knew how much they meant to
me i really hope i articulated that
wow i i didn't actually believe it was a
farewell video at first i thought it was
another one of these
click bait liars who would come back to
the platform within weeks
maybe even days but not you
mcjuggernuggets when you
say something you stick by your word
[Music]
i'm gonna close this off for the last
time forever right chase
i'll help you all to death
and don't forget to keep it rigid
what kind of tagline is that keep it
rigid
who who approve that if you're all
pissed off about getting demonetized i
think i have
the solution i have the crystal ball
maybe don't tell your fans
to keep it rigid and stay lit
okay now you're just playing with me
that's all my fault i that's my fault i
was taking this seriously
your clothes your final words you know
what when you were saying
i i want to say the right words there's
just so much you want to say
the eulogy it's like when somebody
passes away
i don't know what to say i thought to
myself you don't need the right words
but i take that back there aren't right
words but there are wrong words
keep it rigid by the way i know this
looks like i'm being mean to him just
wait
20 seconds okay don't get mad at me for
20 seconds
everything will make sense
check it for life
i have returned one month i want my
youtube channel back please
i don't have any money i need my channel
back
uh guys missed you guys
i think we should have a sit-down
conversation kind of like how i left
this whole thing
i will die by the fire
we got a lot to talk about that is my
guarantee to you i should have never
been so negative towards youtube and
like to be fair i still don't agree with
a lot of things
that they've done especially to me
personally with the monetization and
all those things i talked about before
but i wanted to get into that
i still don't agree with a lot of things
still ban for partner support
but uh i really just wanted to help
people
that's what's brought me back more than
anything i is it what brought you back
more than anything is it really
is it because you weren't too lit over
there you you weren't as rigid as you
remembered
i want to see how you guys are doing i
want to make sure you guys are okay
i know a lot of my audience didn't
follow me over to story fire and that
sucks
this is painful guys this is the life of
a retiring youtuber they always say
i'm retiring that literally means i have
a marketing gimmick a stunt
plan this is a gigantic stunt they're
not actually being genuine
or that's what i did think until i saw
this what's up guys
thank you so much for hitting this page
as you saw from the other video
i'm taking a break and i'm retiring with
a very heavy heart
ladies and gentlemen i don't mean to pat
myself on the back but it takes a big
man to admit when he was wrong and wow
was i wrong
this is maxim trubitsky i used to think
all marketers were the same
till i saw max i see a man of class
of honor someone who wouldn't lie to us
this is a man look at this poor guy he's
in a cast two cast double cast
it's christmas he's laying in bed but he
won't let that stop
him from helping humanity after
talking with doctors for weeks after
talking with my family
flying all of them out here to los
angeles i've decided i will focus
entirely on my recovery from the skiing
accident you focus max you do whatever
you have to do buddy
i i feel bad honestly for accusing these
youtubers of faking retirements
that is not right you know you take all
the time you need you've done so much
for the world
uh so why are you making this video
anyway every single
shopify econ brand we built
and didn't run that we were gonna run in
2021
and the end of 2020 for the holiday
season
because we have about 20 brands that we
built
which are this is a sales pitch
it's just this man broke his arms
literally this man has to use it to sell
you something he cannot he's like billie
jean he can't even go away and leave us
alone he's like i gotta sell hey
i got something for you and it's gonna
cost you but unfortunately i will not be
able to
focus on these new brands so these 20
brands they're already done
right we've been we've built them before
they're already finished we're going to
run them ourselves
so then just run them yourself i don't
understand don't you have a team why
can't you run them yourself
and instead one of you guys if you're
watching this video now you can get
access to
a fully built business a fully done
brand oh
he's just such a nice guy how much is he
selling this for
20 and look only two stores remaining oh
my gosh
only two stores remaining ladies and
gentlemen
terrifying but wait a second what's this
there's another video on his vimeo
account that was left public
oops oh no maxvideo 9 christmas what's
this
he says that he was only selling this to
20 people right he only had 20 stores
what's up guys thank you so much for
being one of the 20 students that now
have your hands
on a brand new business but oops
wait wait wait how many views does this
video have the only people who would
have been watching this
are people who bought the course right
so it's 20 views right
or 21 views because i'm here too
oh what's this 455 does that mean 455
people purchased 20 stores
you're you're telling me that there
weren't only 20 stores
that would have to mean that oh my gosh
santa claus isn't real and there aren't
only two stores remaining oh no way dude
i don't believe it i can't believe it
guys that's
that's impossible next you're gonna tell
me that the tooth fairy isn't real
no way dude no way i don't believe it
dude i think this is honestly my
favorite one because he's monetizing his
own injury and lying about what his
intentions are i'm retiring i'm retiring
you're leaving for two months selling
all the way getting your team's calls
all the way and you're probably not even
leaving for two months
i'm just gonna say this right now
anytime a youtuber
makes a big deal about retiring and oh
my gosh guys i'm sorry i'm going to
leave
90 chance it's fake
i mean i hate to be the bearer of bad
news and everything i hate to be that
guy right
to tell you this to spoil things for you
the
magic of youtube but it's true these
people
oh they just use retirement for click
bait and profit
and i love to see it guys let me know
who your favorite was
of our little series here i think if we
can agree on anything it's that
marketers are a different breed
of human they're just another level
anyways that's it for now
see you next time